uh now to another line from tonight's
trump legal team filing surrounding the
special master quote left unchecked the
doj will impugn leak and publicize
selective aspects of their investigation
with no recourse but to somehow trust
the self-restraint of currently
unchecked investigators here now is
president trump's attorney alina haba as
well as fox news legal analyst greg
jarrett and former florida attorney
general pam bondi good to see you all
let's get your take uh alina first
i think that they were a student they're
filing today i'm i'm proud of the legal
team that brought this up i think the
fact that they did put this picture as
mr turley mentioned was more for the
public eye and that is exactly what
we're not supposed to do it's not about
the public impression it's about justice
and that is not at all what we've seen
out of this administration right now so
unfortunately we're seeing a lot of uh
public play and and i really hope that
we can get the special master put in
place that we can have some
some uh impartial
mediators to look at everything and get
the documents that are supposed to be
with the president back and look at
everything in in a perfect eye look the
the presidential records act protected
him and allowed him to declassify
materials nobody talks about that
instead they look at the three criminal
statutes that they brought
i think our papers are good i'm looking
forward to hearing what the judge has to
say tomorrow pam i'd like to get your
take especially as it relates to the
declassified aspect of this
a president has broad range to
declassify
is that still an issue in question
because i see people on the left they
just automatically dismiss it oh that's
not declassified
how would they know would they know
they wouldn't know sean but the
president trump would know his legal
team would know the council's office
would know and president trump has said
he has declassified these materials he
was the president of the united states
and has the right to do so you know i
think this is a case of who's going to
police the police in this case they
don't want a special master as a career
prosecutor if someone was challenging my
ethics in a court of law and saying
let's bring in an independent person to
look at this i would say gladly please
come in look at the evidence look what
we have if they have nothing to hide
they should welcome a special master
instead of fighting president trump and
his legal team at every single turn
you know first it was the passports greg
jarrett then it's apparently
attorney-client privilege information
that they took out of mar-a-lago i don't
know if that has been returned yet now
it's about a taint team as as you have
rightly pointed out in your columns is
is people investigating themselves
why the mysterious reluctance resistance
towards an objective special master and
how do you cite national security when
you can have somebody with a security
clearance be the special master
yeah
look i i read the court filing and i
must say it is one of the most feeble
and anemic arguments by merrick garland
that i think i've ever read in a court
filing
no legal standing to go to court he
claims
uh my goodness a first year law student
knows that if you're the target of a
search and seizure you have a
constitutional right to go to court and
argue a violation of the fourth
amendment uh to either suppress it or at
the very least have a special master
review and segregate the material the
other part
of what was in the court filing by
garland was this crazy notion of
obstruction of justice what is that you
have to prove that a person acted
corruptly and with an improper purpose
and the united states supreme court has
narrowed it further and said you have to
act uh immorally with a depraved and
evil purpose where is evidence of that
if the president
truly thought he had a right to access
and custody of these presidential papers
there's no corrupt intent here and look
at all of the three criminal statutes
and the warrants cited by garland they
all require knowingly deliberately
willfully breaking the law if the
president said wait a minute this stuff
i declassified it and have a right into
the presidential records act to have
access to it um then you know there
there's no criminal intent here all of
that
is not addressed by merrick garland
instead they throw
a prejudicial and gratuitous photograph
in there meant to be incendiary and
inflammatory they spoon-fed it to the
media it just shows you how ruthless and
depraved merrick garland and his team of
prosecutors are and i'm gonna that's
exactly where i'm headed i'll put that
picture up and keep it up there for a
minute and elena i want to get your take
on this because this was obviously done
for public consumption this was
obviously designed to influence public
opinion i think that is clear as have
all the other leaks as well
um
what happened to the merrick garland
that said oh we'll we'll do all of our
talking in court and in our filings
where's that guy
yeah nowhere what what's happened is now
they've put this picture out so that you
would assume and i'm somebody who has
been and the press loves to talk about
this especially today i'm somebody that
has been in his office i've seen it this
is not the way his office looks they
give you this appearance that you walk
in and there's these top secret
documents just thrown about a b they
don't understand
something could be marked top secret
could be marked classified the
presidential records act he would have
said this is declassified it doesn't get
a new marking all the time he's left the
office it is a complete public spectacle
and i'm not really going to stand by it
anymore you know i personally have
gotten intimidated people have tried to
intimidate me it's not going to work you
can't just put a picture like this and
say look
did the fbi do that or was that the way
that room looked before they went in
there do you have any any first-hand
knowledge yeah i'm sure you've seen the
press today i do have first hand
knowledge as you know i have been down
there i'm down there frequently i have
never seen that i have never ever seen
that that is not the way his office
looks anybody that knows president
trump's office he has guests frequently
there it is
it's just a joke they literally must
have gone in and taken out documents
they wanted or cover letters as it is
and put it about so that the public
believes that this is top secret
documents that were on his floor
it's ridiculous i can tell you
personally it's ridiculous i've never
seen that
pam so what we're really looking at here
is the department of justice the fbi
staging a picture to influence public
opinion wouldn't that also if god forbid
with all the speculation about a
possible indictment wouldn't that also
obtain a jury pool isn't that also
designed to taint public opinion against
donald trump by laying it out that way
and shouldn't merrick garland say we
laid it out that way we took that
picture we released that picture and
then he should be answering questions i
think before congress well why didn't
you
keep to your word
and do all of your talking in court and
where are all these other leaks coming
from
yeah absolutely sean and elena's right
his office is very neat orderly i he i
could never ever see him leaving
anything classified previously
classified at any time classified laying
out in the open this was made to taint a
jury to taint public perception of him
they've been doing this for seven years
and they're getting desperate the
midterms are coming up then 2024.
they're at the end of their rope and
they're doing anything they can to hurt
him all the search warrants i've been
involved in no one would ever pull
things out and lay them out that way it
makes no sense other than they're still
trying to destroy the president and it's
not going to work
all right great analysis all of you pam
thank you alina thank you greg jarrett
as always thank you